so will smith addresses oscar slap in a
new video okay i don't know i don't know
if we can play this i don't think we can
play this tyler
so uh uh uh before the youtube folks
show up i don't know if we can play this
or not but let me read this to you so
will smith
will smith is deeply remorseful about
slapping chris rock at the academy
awards in march smith posted a video on
his instagram account on friday that
began with the words on screen it's been
a minute i was fogged out by that point
smith said it's all fuzzy i've reached
out to chris and the message that came
back from his campus he's not ready to
talk and when he is he will reach out so
i will say to chris i apologize to my
behavior was unacceptable and i'm here
whenever you are ready to talk smith
also apologizes to rock's mother family
and his brother tony rock
who has stared in 2007 sitcom start in
2007 sitcom all of us which was created
by smith and his wife jada pinkett smith
adam since this is more in your
wheelhouse what are your thoughts on
this
man will i mean what a fall from grace
this guy's had i mean
the even the
the apology tour that he's on right now
was just sad there's nothing manly about
will smith anymore this is [ __ ] will
smith well french fresh prince of bel
air men in black
independence day
like the the pursuit of happiness the
list goes on
and all he's doing is crying and
apologizing these days
and making amends for his wife banging
some dude dude okay
dudes i i
number one
how long ago was the slap two months ago
no the slap
way but wow four five four months ago no
i was still in l.a no it was may a few
months ago yeah so what took so long and
this is the best you can come up with
i'm just so disappointed with what i'm
seeing with will smith he needs to get
some red pill in his life yeah okay he
needs to get like there's something that
he can do to change his reputation
what's that it's only one thing he needs
to [ __ ] slap someone else and not
apologize to divorce
100 agreement that's the only thing he
can do to change his reputation and i'm
telling you right now because look i'm
i've seen men who were man's men yeah
okay
date a woman and gradually that woman
changed the man okay i read a quote a
long time ago that was given to me
before i was getting married and this is
what the quote said
and i was thinking about getting married
in a different time i wasn't ready and
the guy that gave me the counsel i'm
like yeah this is not a good time for me
to get married quote was
women marry man
hoping
they change and they don't
men marry women hoping they stay the
same and they don't okay woman change
man stays the same unless if a man
allows a woman to change them
into who he is now today because now
you're scared you're walking on
eggshells and when a man is in that web
they rarely know they're in that web and
they get destroyed they do they lose
their dna and eventually you're in so
deep that you're convinced you're
supposed to be this person it's
treacherous to be in that situation i
think there's only one thing he can do
if he announced tomorrow
that he's found divorce and he's sick of
it hey love you we had a good run but i
gotta move on and i gotta go live my
life
i will tell you three six twelve months
later everything about his reputation
would would change and people would say
finally he's standing up for himself
that is the only way for him to be out
hundred percent because fans will come
back that he lost will come back will
either needs to go be by himself a
little bit and do some soul searching
and i'm sure he's not gonna be buying
i'm sure there's a lineup of plenty of
people that would love to find out what
the principal is up to yeah but at the
same time you know he needs to get
somebody that's crazy about him that
wants to be with him
you know versus the other way around i
think he was crazy about jada versus
jada being crazy about him i think jada
was like yeah i should marry somebody
like will smith well versus will's like
i'm crazy about her he's got to find
somebody that's crazy about him to see
what that's going to work and her first
love was tupac from what i recall so
that's
different so you're not let me ask you
and let me ask you another question yeah
what we haven't talked about maybe
what's the elephant in the room is
hollywood he's as hollywood as it gets
at this point so like
everything about him i just feel is like
okay what what are the people in
hollywood are gonna say how am i gonna
how are they gonna respond to what i'm
doing right now i i mean what's my
career looking like what's the box
office what's the movies yeah what are
the you know the producers saying the
executive producers like everything's
just very calculated it seems
correct in hollywood it doesn't seem to
be like yeah i'm the [ __ ] man i'm do
talk [ __ ] about my wife i [ __ ]
how many new projects let me ask you any
questions let me ask you guys a question
let me ask you guys a question
say jada's dating tupac and they're
married yeah
would that if that would have happened
what does tupac do
in this situation say jade is married to
tupac tupac's alive and they're together
and jade is like oh i had an
entanglement what does tupac do first of
all tupac won't do that interview nope
tupac wouldn't be with her and jada
wouldn't be able to do that to tupac
but what does tupac do
whatever the [ __ ] he wants he divorces
he hooks up with the honest girl
the hottest girl that's trending that
he's gonna find actually think about
what tupac would do i mean he cuts her
off he says thanks for you know thanks
for all that you've done you're out the
door we're going to take a ride with
biggie i'll sit in the middle you sit by
the door
yeah what do you think
like he kills the guy
no no no the buck's not going to kill
the guy tupac is going to make a song
about it oh yeah for sure is gonna make
a song about it but he's called him up
yeah he's gone you know he's gonna say
hit her up you know you know because
i've moved on that's what the name of
the song is gonna be not hit him up so
is there anything that will smith can do
aside from making a song like
is there anything he can do aside
nothing from divorcing to regain his
reputation nothing zero nothing zero
nothing that's again remember it's my
opinion no again nothing but if you're
counseling him you say listen buddy
i know you've had a good run without
data it's time to cut it off guys say
one thing about you know you guys know
what that was that that
well-lit production of him saying i'm
sorry that's the studios that's his
agent his manager that's his publicist
saying listen
you're not making the movies right now i
don't know if he is or not we're losing
billions of [ __ ] dollars because
you're not the starring dude because to
be honest with some people don't even
want to go see him right now so that yo
do
he couldn't get the next deal and now
his publicist is like we got to do this
yeah because at the end of the day if
you're going to be a a-list
they're not going to come to you
remember when tom cruise had a weird
moment and he gets into it matt lauer on
the pills and then and then was it after
that that he was jumping on oprah's
couch
i think i
was
very close first of all tom was right
he was right tom was right i agree with
you tom was right of course he was right
that interview but let me let me go back
to the point you just made and you kind
of given that point about the fact that
uh uh the publicists are like hey what
are you doing you got to get this job
done okay there comes a time in your
life
where you're
in the goat community and this isn't
this isn't everybody only a few people
get to say this okay in their space will
smith is in the goat status of his space
you know
he he's in a goat community of what he
did okay
who gives a [ __ ] what your publicists
say who cares what the fans say who
cares what anybody says bro you killed
it dog like what are you thinking about
like do you realize forget all of us
forget everything what the hell do you
want to do and are you happy inside make
that decision stop listening to freaking
publicist or anybody including us
whatever we're saying make the he knows
what the right decision is make that
decision and move on and stop acting
because that's an act when he got up and
made that video with chris you're acting
like um um you know how they say you
should never do arms and acting it's
acting like um i'm not you know um i
mean um
like you're trying to be natural you're
not natural we can tell you're not
you're acting and it's it's very
uncomfortable to even watch us take a
break from everybody
freaking go hang out with monks for a
month do something away from everybody
and decide what you want to do because
the world loved the will who was will
nobody likes a guy that's acting like
trying to be somebody else that the
publicist or the media or the market or
hollywood wants you to be no one's
turned on by that nobody take a page out
of this tate guy that's going viral why
do you think he is going viral because
he doesn't give a [ __ ] what you think
his background i've never done business
with this guy i don't know what is back
everybody's asking me about what about
this and what about that and what about
this i think most of people in the world
are pissed because how viral he's going
and how much you know what do you call
it how much attention he's getting how
come i'm not getting it the algorithms
are favoring him he's got a better
strategy than you ask yourself well why
is he doing so well
why is he doing something he's an
unapologetic badass that says what's on
his mind that's what will smith needs
but so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]